let me relate to you the most dreadful
of scenarios a two-and-a-half year olds
been potty-trained has an accident and
the events that unfold result in the
sexual molestation torture and eventual
beating to death of this little girl a
63 year old grandmother is stabbed to
death in her car and the killer forces
her granddaughter to drive alongside her
lifeless body these examples above are
real and the men convicted of those
crimes will be among the first to be
affected by the new federal death
penalty declared by Donald Trump the
arguments for and against capital
punishment
may divide many of us and they deserve
to be deeper than our initial emotional
reactions indeed in researching this
topic I've seen my own view
flip-flopping forward and back but I've
reached the sad conclusion that there
are some people who are so far outside
the confines of a civil society who are
truly beyond the realm of redemption and
rehabilitation and who have disregarded
the human rights of others in the most
brutal ways and for those exceptional
circumstances
once the burden of proof has been is
entirely fulfilled it is justified that
capital punishment should be considered
at least we shall I actually don't think
it's possible for me to disagree with
you more on this subject I was expecting
that you're talking about civil society
now I think that any civil society
should have as a minimum that the state
the government does not kill its own
citizens when you look at the countries
that do do that we have Iran North Korea
China Saudi Arabia no coincidence
they're some of the most repressive
regimes in the world and that's not the
sort of company that I would wish to be
in so just on moral and ethical grounds
I really strongly disagree but aside
from all of that we have the practical
grounds so most of the experts on this
issue are saying
this does not the death penalty does not
work as a death penalty as a deterrent
to some of the most appalling crimes
like the ones that you're describing
which are completely horrific it also
that runs the risk of killing an
innocent person since 1973 a hundred and
sixty-six people on death row have been
exonerated and cleared and the other
problem is that the there are half of
the people sitting on death row are
people of color so we have a system that
is racially biased and I think that's
another serious concern I'm absolutely
with Rachel two on this I think there is
there's no argument for on terms of cost
there's an argument against it in terms
of risk and in terms of the prejudice
against people of color half of whom are
sitting in death row which is a
disproportionate number the other thing
I would say is we don't dispute the
horrible crimes that people do what
we're disputing is whether it's right
for the state or even the federal
government to kill those people for
those crimes and I think that the
prejudice that it causes in terms of
society at large is too great for us to
carry that risk so let's just hear now
from Robert Brett Dunham who's the
executive director of the death penalty
Information Center it has emphasized the
very rare examples of murders committed
by immigrants as a way to suggest to the
American public and the world at large
that immigrants pose a disproportionate
danger to the American public the facts
show that's not the case it's an
argument that plays into the rhetorical
campaign that we've been seeing in
Washington exactly say what Brett Dunham
is saying is that Donald Trump is using
this as a wedge issue in the election to
against minorities and to whip up his
base and let's not forget guys this is
the very same man who 1989 took out a
full-page
paid for from his own money saying bring
back the death penalty which led to the
conviction of five innocent young black
teenagers who were convicted wrongfully
of raping a jogger in Central Park they
spent years in jail all these young
black kids Trump whipped up a mob
against them and he wanted them to be
executed had he succeeded five innocent
black teenagers not only would have had
their lives ruined they would have had
no lives left and of course they were
completely exonerated through eventually
through DNA evidence um what concerns me
is the point you touched on with your
response to Michelle Rachel and that is
that if you look at the five countries
Michelle in the world that have this as
the the ones that execute the most
commonly in the world China you know
Iran Saudi Arabia Vietnam and Iraq are
the top five why would anyone want to
join that Club because the value they
place on life and death in those
societies it is clearly not that much
and what I worry about isn't that these
people deserve to be executed what I
worry about is who deserves to be the
executioner and what that does to a
society when it places life and death in
the hands of a of a process is it well
it's not just follow majesty point I
think the bigger problem here is that
you say it's about heinous crimes the
problem is different societies will have
a different idea what is eNOS so in some
societies you have professed a wrong
religion bang yeah it's all over some
societies you are gay or lesbian bang
it's all now so this idea that actually
you know there's a kind of standard that
says you can be done in for this that in
the other it's just not true it's
actually just cultural death for
adultery I think exactly exactly how
would that play yeah as we have seen and
that and that the other point I really
wanted to make about this is that you
know you say the Trump may think he's at
some level some kind of divinity but the
problem is when he does these things if
those guys had been executed you can't
bring them back yep I know not gods and
that's what I think is a real problem
to be the sanctions tunnel truck yeah
well yes I have thought through what
many of you have said because for me
personally I always used to reply to
this issue immersively so I used to hear
oh my god this is a horrible crime yes
they deserve this and I've started
challenging myself for the purpose of
this debate and what I'm listening to
you guys arguing with me against is
wrongful execution so we're the wrong
person has been executed which I agree
is terrible and shouldn't happen we make
human judgments based on who's guilty
and who's not we don't need to be doing
that anymore the death penalty should
only be applied if indeed it is going to
be and by the way any argument that we
are not the people who can judge Monteux
punishment but in the cases where there
is indisputable scientific evidence and
the case is if you're referring to
central pact robbers that's decades ago
and DNA has moved on in fact it was DNA
that helped clear them if there's if
there's indisputable DNA evidence that
somebody has committed a heinous what do
you what do you do about the case that
we've seen in China quite recently where
Akai was done and then they discovered
that actually been fitted up by the
police
just sitting these backward nation
because I always listen to you law and I
always get thrown I'm not doing on this
topic is I'm very passionate about it
and at the end of the day what I think
is if you have a system in place that
it's gonna counter things so you're
saying about its prejudice well actually
if you had a fairer system in place
you're saying about wrongful things if
you use proper DNA then we're talking
about the end of the day you have to
think why do you want somebody if you
imagine a child and I know you've got
children Majid imagine the horrific
scenario where somebody has sexually
molested your child has tortured them
battered them to death what you wanna do
stick them in a prison now Michelle this
is exactly the point I'm making
of course I'd want to kill that person
and the question is should but should I
be allowed to kill that person yeah no
no if I was left to my own devices I
would kill that person should society
tolerate my emotional
reaction to the torture of my own child
no because what does it do to society
let's have a look at this map look at
the u.s. look at how many states have
the death penalty that's 29 states in
which they kill people now I think
there's no there's no it's not a
coincidence that the United States of
America that legally sanctions the death
penalty also has a prison population
higher than some countries and has mass
shootings in malls and everyone's
carrying guns around because the value
of life and death in cultures that
legally sanction executing people is is
you've got to admit is lower than in
those societies where they don't it's
simply it's you know we could observe
that so my point is what it does to us
not what it in life and the Anacin
Amnesty International they keep talking
about human rights and human life the
valuing human rights is a two-way
contract it's a - you cannot breach
people's human rights left right and
center and then sit there crying they
respect my human rights you're not
addressing well address in my life but
also you have these people in the UK
what people get life they don't sit
there for their full lives right what
would it do to you if you executed
somebody that's my point
well I would not whether they deserve I
wouldn't execute anyone that would be
weird and I would be a murderer but I
don't work in that system yeah